let's talk about a singing on the voice
last night a new champ was crowned as
Team Blake ruled again but Blake was so
humble and victory yeah right the winner
of the voice is Sunday I'm really happy
that I was able to be the coach that
coached the winner and Adam was not I
feel really good not sure what's going
on you're not sure what's caught up on
that everything's great you didn't even
go to the after-party last night I
didn't plan on winning so I didn't pack
anything okay that's five wins for Blake
making him the winningest coach in the
show's history but after 11 seasons the
voice which gives the winner a record
deal has yet to produce a chart-topping
star and that's not sitting well with
blank I want to personally issue a
challenge to Universal Records we need
to make the record and put the work
behind it that he deserves it means a
lot to me too just to know that he
really really believes and cares that
much we reached out to Universal Music
Group which didn't respond for comment
in time for our deadline but Sundance
won a lot more than just a shot at
stardom it got to rock out with his
idols kiss
Bruno Mars Kelly Clarkson Ariana Grande
and John Legend also performed on last
night's star-studded finale I don't know
who after next season
Miley sitting out and when's coming back
and that just sounds like another win
for Blake we're both excited and
high-fiving and and partying about it
when we got the news but Gwen is special
you know and she deserves this